oh I wasn't drinking no no how do we
[Laughter]
which is an heirloom from a grandfather
but you kept the spot chair he's very
paranoid about the pajama button in his
crotch so he keeps fixing his Rollo is
are you I'm doing quarterblack Garrett
is here we H are doing audio of course
and hold on really quickly before we go
to fact check the morning news let's see
what they have on CNN real quick state
with nearly 28,000 cases overall how
dare they some states to reopen despite
warnings from whom you don't think it's
a good idea we will be talking today
about quite a bit we'll be talking what
dr. Burke's talking about the death
rates but first again the promo code is
quarantine you gets $30 off this is huge
hashtag mug Club quarantine months we've
doubled up the content for you hopefully
let us know hopefully this has been of
use to you hopefully it's acted as a
south for you you know if not it's a big
we're unemployment and live chat of
course for people who are watching live
at the blaze exclusively mug that
members just list your name since for
some reason I don't know with all the
millions of dollars developed in the
platform and we'll be reading some of
those from you Dan Crenshaw's North
Friday oh he was supposed to be on but
he couldn't he's a busy man he didn't
have a death perception to hit the video
call it wasn't available wow he can see
he just gauge the depth right like you
with color yeah true no Shaw should
spend it spend you're colorblind his
depth issues but together you would be
like that Karen
I'll confirm the mighty yes we're one
complete person together anyway anyone
remember the mighty nope really two
disabled people I don't know if [ __ ]
is disabled your nerdy like me
the mighty no I was a bully a big bully
and I think was Kirin cannot McCauley
okay I don't remember any I don't know
did was on his shoulders and so kinda
like a little rascals you know in the
triode only they live their life that
way and together they like their whole
life now and you know as much about the
physical limitations but they also
learned about themselves emotionally
spiritually intellectually oh well
horrible edgy stuff I highly recommend
it actually I don't remember what I did
that with the pagemaster and I
recommended it and the tweets were
radically upset oh I get it child's
movie yes it's a fine film turtles -
that is so secretive you can never
really tell what's your secret news no
what comes to you check this this has
been going on in the Morning News so
there's been a 60 million dollar pop up
hospital people been talking about this
because it was necessary saying Houston
that's a lot it's now been sitting empty
for two weeks we'll probably shut down
the expenses safety officers the day
rates for $2,800 $2,300 in two thousand
dollars a finance section chief at
twenty eight seventy five a day to
public information officers at two
thousand day basically thousand yet they
were making over two thousand a day
between two and three thousand to sit in
an so that CNN could berate Donald Trump
for now building enough of are you I'm
trying to do math in my head yeah two
thousand a day is a lot yeah math
without the Asian rap will prove a
fruitless endeavor even on a temporary
basis that's highway robbers come on
and then we're going to be talking about
the YouTube and all of the social media
and what their new rules now obvious
with the World Health Organization so my
question
you actually out there is a day often in
good morning my sorry I just saw the
freaking headline here why do you care I
care about Texas I care what Texas does
Yeah right we talk they talk about
Houston earlier you live in Dallas what
I know I don't live in Dallas but still
then come on through May 15th why you
know what you know who needs to make a
stand against this quick trip you're the
only to make VARs pivot right don't be
waiting for those 7-eleven Jonny Quest
buddies to come on in they aren't doing
it that was a roundabout way to say
[ __ ] so or race to try almost were a
racetrack racetrack
what are they terrible exactly that's
all they are exactly the essence it was
a soft lob from the mighty children's
film the mighty an antonín matter of
fact for this program so what do you
think of social media's role during the
whole outbreak of the corona virus it
there is a balance right do you think I
need to shut down fake conspiracy
theories where people are deliberately
trying to mislead the public into
selling them something you know some
snake oil I understand that but are you
also a little bit leery of YouTube
Facebook Twitter the alphabet networks
here yeah I guess alphabet is the the
parent company of Google but they might
as well be the alphabet networks no
that's how I even refer to ABC NBC CBS
right that is ABC NBC CBS that is Google
YouTube Brent Facebook Twitter Facebook
owns Instagram I don't know what Twitter
owns yeah I don't know I'm amazed
Twitter is still like a third wheel Jack
right well my wife and I we're talking
about this last night like that's one of
the major differences with you know what
we have now and what we had in 2009 what
we had in 2003 and we've seen like every
five to ten years there is an outbreak
somewhere of something like this right
maybe not the exact same thing yeah what
was different and it's like the
immediate access to information is so
much different now I still remember the
the o3 outbreak of Zenga yeah
no no you don't bad news still feeling
the havoc
it was Rica xanga I too or Zima just a
bunch of Asians yeah
finding ways to bypass pornography
filters Friendster and then there was my
face yeah which brought us the likes of
Tia tequila and I think Jeffrey star so
thank you for that huh thank you Tom
he was a good friend that didn't sound
genuine really yeah you pick up you know
what maybe if you and weigh together you
can be the mighty as it comes like
picking social cues burgers then Wade's
gut-punching snide that's true yeah
opponent yeah the funny is wait is that
you know this belt Wade
I love audio way but audio way and
sometimes he will say the most self
esteem shatteringly oh yeah insults yes
and like he's throwing it in the trash
ya can use walking about it anyway like
oh my god but I love you guys what you
fall to your knees as he passes by
family issue that caused rifts in there
yeah he just owns you okay all right so
let me know what you think of what is
the role of social media if at all let
me see this I think it's an actor
musician actor that's why they only you
can say this just talk to this guy whose
car
I used to Jack my car was Jack it's true
have no regard for my personal property
he right he right and now I have car
shields and he just adds for me he right
my bad the director in the background
with ice geez name on it right so you
could you knew who it was for some race
guys is something I will say we have to
move on the actual news oh but you know
if punk rock bands remember if they
became pop you say
yeah happy I'm popular we're it's not
even their fault other people like their
music there was considered sellouts yep
with rappers that's the goal yeah
eventually you two can sell out so yeah
if Green Bay for example if we Billy Joe
what Billie Joe Armstrong he made a
cameo in in deep blue sea mm-hmm
no like that's good that's gonna be good
for you yeah good Charlotte made a cameo
charlet we're doing advertising for now
our shield your careers done at that
point you've taken a different path oh
wow look they're doing a commercial it's
pretty much about on par with the
writing of all your other songs Good
Charlotte yes which one of you is the
evil twin not entirely sure you see you
let's help out a hairdo but now neither
one of them have here oh so let's get to
this this is this was a chilling I don't
know if you guys have watched this clip
I want to set this up for you we did the
live stream yesterday obviously with the
the dr. Burke's who just and now this is
is this from CNN I think this clip this
is Susan Wojcicki YouTube CEO while we
talk about social media we talk about
their role I understand that they have a
bias we noticed this when we first
started doing the any of the COBIT
videos back then I was still called them
it was still called wolf loop and then
coronavirus and no one says coronavirus
anymore they all say Kovac Kovac yeah I
just they've gotten lazy well I don't
know but I've also heard people
epidemiologist refer to it as a disease
as opposed to a virus huh I thought that
I thought there's a like HIV is the
virus and AIDS is a disease like HIV I
thought that was the conscience and AIDS
is Tom Hanks in Philadelphia right yeah
I thought and then I don't know if there
was somewhere in between Jared Leto
Dallas buyers club I have no idea I
don't know the progression but I know
there's a difference we know virus and a
disease so I will tell you this I'm not
a PD ologist but I believe it's a virus
but this was Susan we just keep talking
about their approach here at Google and
YouTube in what's really scary here is
what she flat-out to see if you can spot
what she flat-out declares to be a
violation of policy which will directly
affect a
let's go till we talk about that is
raising authoritative information but
then we also talk about removing
information that is problematic and of
course anything that is medically
unsubstantiated to people saying like
take vitamin C you know that's tumeric
like those are all will cure those are
the examples of solutions that would be
a violation of our policy anything that
would go against World Health
Organization recommendations would be a
violation of our policy and so remove is
another really important part of our
policy so you're not just putting in
that the truth next to the lie you're
taking the lie down that's a pretty
aggressive approach yeah as opposed to
brian Stelter who wanted to go down the
line was a former wrestler stationed at
Safeway no I was just I was just
thinking like our audience usually
seeing one of those in a video is enough
for poison yeah yeah we do apologize yes
and you were saying brian Stelter he's
what he's age yeah Brian brian Stelter I
totally forget about this yes brian
Stelter is two years older than you Wow
what yeah Susan Wojcicki is four years
younger
oh it's all that all that puddling
essence just hurry I think I think
you're dumb enough to believe that
vitamin C will cure you of a disease by
this point like my sister actually is
some intravenous vitamin C that it is
effective against a lot of viruses at
high doses not taking air bits not great
if you're anything right there's one
thing we'll say I've had to have
conversate had to have conversations off
air with dr. Choi and other medical
experts you got a little nose we'll have
a protocol that we're taking here based
on the recommendation of a doctor we
said this is a good preventative measure
to take so you are guaranteed no but I
can talk about it on air because if I
tell you what we're taking up we will be
considered spreading fake news and it's
not really and what a preventative
measure that they're studying right now
that has been showing a lot of promise
we have to take three pills a day here
that are supplements that are lab tested
we get from a certified lab can't tell
you so good luck that at least they
clean their stuff very frequently that
quick trip you need
oh my days please do this so I can stop
hearing this any spots of the show they
sponsor we're in here it is so she said
you see anything that goes against the
World Health Organization will be
removed really I heard a collective they
want to sound nice we wrote health
organization but go back to our videos
that we've we've done on this
they don't recognize Taiwan at all and
that wouldn't be so sinister for example
like let's say they didn't recognize
Palestine as a country because of course
it's not a country it never has been in
the rest of the Arab world didn't want
them they said you go over there and the
Jews were like how about us and they're
like no no we want it back anyway the
point is nice little plate the point is
Taiwan the reason that Taiwan is Taiwan
is because of gross abuses of human
rights yes when they talk about you know
you see like Hotel Rwanda with the
second guy from iron man to be parents
Howard ask for too much money oh yeah
that was ah that guy he was in Hotel
Rwanda people talk about Darfur they
talk about all these humanitarian crises
right abroad and here's what I am more
convinced now that when they don't have
a dog in the fight that's when liberals
that's when the left feigns outrage
because right here this is right at our
doorstep World Health Organization they
have the opportunity to take a stand and
say hold on a second you refused to even
acknowledge that Taiwan exists nor
representative hung up on a Skype call
when asked about Taiwan and it matters
because why let's say let's say someone
in Taiwan let's say a government from
Taiwan government official from Taiwan
released a video that was equivalent to
the emails that they sent to the well
health organization I believe in
December if I'm not mistaken about this
in front of me December yeah December
they sent them email to the World Health
Organization saying hey you know how
you're saying that corona virus can't be
transmitted from human human contact we
have studies right here a verifiable
data that proves that's not true yeah
they ignored it with health World Health
Organization's they do not incorporate
it imagine if Taiwan created a YouTube
video saying hey you know so you know
right World Health Organization is wrong
it can be transferred from human to
human contact this broad Susan Wojcicki
would remove it because of her political
motivation that is terrifying well and
they they become the arbiters of truth
who do you do who do you trust do you
trust an organization like the w-h-o
who's now being looked at to be defunded
by the United States because they
coddled up next to China in the face of
overwhelming evidence that they should
have been a little bit more critical of
how they were approaching the sea-mist
you should coddled up they coddled China
they canoodle dug up they take a new
China and then they were arrested by a
policeman for not just or not that was a
reasonable response but that Susan
Wojcicki and their crew now get to tell
you what information is real and what is
not and yeah I'm sorry but I I like free
speech I like the ability to go through
I hate stuff that's fake on on YouTube
and other places like alright everybody
does right can we all just agree on that
of course I still want the opportunity
to see it because you guys would be
saying that it's fake the stuff that
Taiwan was saying just like to your
point and if that's what they've said
that our stuff is fake when our still
that's correct yes when we talk about
the World Health Organization by the way
this is all you want to talk about
identity politics know that the head of
the World Health Organization said that
it was racist for Taiwan to criticize oh
well god that's yeah well well the left
has made it clear that they will just
listen to some somebody because they
have some kind of authoritative name
yeah so we're like China is claiming
some amount of authority for themselves
and so they listen to them the whu-oh
claims as has the World Health
Organization it has their name and the
left will go okay and the people on the
right tend to have at least some part of
them that goes I don't know seems to be
a direct correlation with the left in
credibility with a given spokesperson
yeah yeah with fouls the number of power
also melanin sure I'd these are big
determining factors so let me get this
straight
a Taiwan puts out a report that could
have helped the entire world the w-h-o
ignores them in Taiwan says hey you
probably shouldn't ignore this and he
said racist yeah come on up there Gibby
gurbles garbles this is Lyle if you know
you son of a [ __ ] I think you I think
he was just pulling up
and that overlay maybe maybe he'll do it
if you call him a Nazi propagandist
that's gonna spur him on that oh by the
way I was also huge dick no Ned Flanders
Wow wait come on that's a given
we know he's gotta have something going
for him I mean is it racist if it's a
compliment I'm sure he jumps I'm sure
that guy has a I am curious to see if
they bring up Florida again on CNN
because they just dropped their death
rate estimate by 700 that's the first
you're going to see the death rate right
under the drop like flies and I'll get
into that a little bit later uh which
but here's something else I think was it
called dragon fly yeah this is something
important dragon fly Google and YouTube
so when you talk about the World Health
Organization and you talk about Taiwan
you talk about the grosses beat abuses
of human rights you talk about them
silencing voices of dissent then it's
important to note that Google and
YouTube they were working on a search
engine where they could censor people I
think it was called dragon flight to
work with the government of China as far
as crazy you can't do business in the
United States if you do that yeah yeah
and they were planning on launching it
this year is it would that be it would
that be abuse of power
if I were president that for me would be
an executive order any business that
decides to actually cater to the Chinese
government censorship not you can't sell
your products in China of course not not
you can't have an import-export
coordinator based in China of course not
but if a company is creating a
subsidiary to specifically appease and
work with Chinese government censorship
laws you can't do business in the US you
have to pick that that makes sense to me
right and so if you are in China's doing
this exact same thing if you or if you
recognize Taiwan if you're a
multinational corporation or if you're
somebody that's trying to go in you
can't go in there and say yeah Taiwan's
an independent nation and let in China
let you do business with now they won't
let you do that right and it's not like
they were censoring small things right
like you know bad memes about their
leaders it was about freedom democracy
dissenters religion right all of these
topics that people are gonna talk about
all over the world they're like we don't
want any of that because every time we
have some of that stuff a whistleblower
comes out we have to kill them we have
to kill him every but you know
youtube/google and in the alphabet
networks and World Health Organization
they're the figurative tank running
mowing down the guy in Tiananmen Square
they really are right now it is
remarkable to me they're making it
possible for them to do that I don't
they are obviously they'll make that
possible if it comes down to that but I
mean in the realm of speech realm or
discourse they are actually assisting
the big guy well they're yeah they're
attempting to bring separate nations
tyrannical rules here right at least and
operate in the digital space which
increasingly because of this Kovach
thing has become the only space right
yeah sure yeah good point and you made a
point the other day when we were talking
about this like if you do that if you
play that game it basically it's the
lowest common denominator becomes the
rules for everybody so we have a crisis
but we got it we got to throw it away
because they have a really shitty system
over there right right exactly
since we have to play by there when
people say that's ethnocentric okay okay
sorry eccentric to say that our system
that affords citizens rights is better
than the system of China okay if you
hear that and you interpret through the
lens of ethnicity or silly person much
like my comments about the World Health
Organization it's silly had nothing to
do with race and everything to do with
culture so he is avin ed Flanders
culture yeah can you hear the dog
whistle yeah exactly I think actually
right behold on right now steady no
benefits potentially danger with
hydroxychloroquine which again they show
minority families dying they're talking
about I think was Van Jones said
yesterday this will be a death sentence
for people of color in the United States
if we reopen the economy and what what
does that even mean they want us to
think it's like they're yourself yeah
we'll do people of color not have jobs
yes they do like they there's the
assumption a lot of those in the left
yeah well they benefit
disproportionately are just going to die
that right this is the only change that
will happen
well yes people will die people are
constantly dying of different things but
yes they also have jobs they also will
be showing up to work or
not depending on whether or not people
will also have kids that need to feed
right anyone else take tremendous
pleasure knowing that Van Jones is the
man who is ultimately trying to appease
obviously the black base but has no fans
whatsoever from think that many black
Americans are watching CNN travel with
his own show he's buried on Anderson
Cooper that'd be like burying def Comedy
Jam is a commercial break and Mary Tyler
Moore oh wait
who's that Monique oh my hat though
because it still got the stick on it
yeah because you know I got my threads I
just saw that yesterday so I really was
walking he had stickers on his hat but
still think he had tags any shed is
still a thing and his shoes were red his
pants were red his belt was red his hat
was red his shirt was black and then he
had a gold backpack on he's just puttin
it y-you had stickers on go and how
expensive is that because you know all
of his outfits must be just as
color-coordinated which I can appreciate
look we're where are you getting this
money I think you just had recently
stolen them all gosh I just save up for
Goldeneye for n64 yeah did you imagine
if had to get new new kicks every time
there was a grand opening and people
waited outside
and by the way Congo popped I'm talking
about the actual pup tents in Congo
Congo yeah the tents they threw up and
went oh yeah they were fantastic yeah
and then I think they were do they
really work
I don't we used to have them at Canadian
Tire in Canada I really just wanted that
so like self-tracking gun system that
was Canadian Tire was our was like our
Home Depot only they had something
called Canadian Tire money Canadians out
there will know this and I had a kid at
school who tried to counterfeit Canadian
Tire money
what was that beep I don't know
something go wrong I was about to go in
here do we only to duck under a desk and
yeah kiss her ass good-bye
[Laughter]
so Canadian Tire man he tried to
counterfeit Canadian Tire money and then
tried to counterfeit tickets to the
school talent show really it wasn't it
was immediately discovered early on huh
it wasn't it didn't taste it the comics
Dark Knight just used like normal
construction that right
a buddy crayon yeah a buddy of mine did
something like that east to collect
baseball cards and he signed a Nolan
Ryan baseball card like in like almost
print you know not cursive letter like
you know if you ever want to see your
kid alive again right in just those
blocks and was like oh that's that's not
signed by him he's like no really it is
all it sell it to you for a hundred
bucks then you you you were wise when
you saw that he signed your Hank Aaron
card Mickey Mantle yes
that's what did it not good I'm
impressed you knew both of those
negligence well I watch Sandlot so
before we move on we do have to I know
that many of you have been affected by
this uh stay at home order the
quarantine and so I think we have them
on the line if I'm not mistaken it's
time for a traffic report with our very
own senior traffic report correspondent
Thomas Finnegan
[Music]
all right mr. Finnegan are you there sir
how are you I am here Steven I have
successfully crashed landed the
helicopter oh good that's Wow I don't
know what to tell you well how about you
how about you tell me about the the
traffic this morning Thomas since that's
why you're on the payroll I can't tell
you much about the traffic but I'm gonna
have to let you go I got some needless
to deal with well it sound in the
background Thomas what's it yeah what
sound oh my do we just lose oh oh he's
gone the guy is the reiatives to do and
somewhat to be native I think he said
natives where was where US helicopter ah
this is an air traffic report with
Thomas Finnegan let's move on
[Music]
let's make sure someone checks on yeah
yeah yeah well one less mouth to feed I
guess silver linings I don't know one of
these days we'll need to get some
traffic report though yeah well it would
be helpful one of these days we'll need
to get a legitimate traffic reporter
yeah and a new health point though wait
Plaza Tyson shuts down Waterloo Iowa
plant linked to virus outbreak on the
left is Tyson I usually don't talk with
female reporters and let they fornicate
it with him so you should probably stop
putting me in the quadrant view unless
you want it you know here's the thing
they talked about Florida this morning
they were talking about Florida why no
mention of it now why no matter how
horrible it is right they're reopening
Florida can you believe this the beaches
but now that Florida has lowered its
death estimate by 70 percent not a peep
from this guy who I don't know who he is
but there's something that really
bothers me about him I realize what it
is figure that's his nose and you know
he's not tough enough to have had it
broken in a boxing fight right you're
talking about the host yeah yeah yeah
well it does seem like he like maybe was
standing behind the wrong Golf Club yeah
something like that
something girls croquet a club is that a
wrap we figured out it's a mallet mallet
no you're not sure izing steak with it
I'll ofone mallet true care what anyone
says every day watch out for those
Ryan's baby Ryan humor it's a genre show
this is something I wondered after we
did our live stream yesterday of the
press briefing and terrorized so much
people by the way I hate to say because
I actually have good friends of [ __ ] we
Pete Fox did you really it was just we
threw it together last minute because
people are desperate people are
thirsting for these press briefings and
I think you have a lot of people that
fox news runs them I think on their on
their Channel but most of the main news
channels that are appearing you know
they're youtube friendly that don't
derive any World Health Organization
they're not necessarily broadcasting it
so they've had a ton of people tuning in
so thank you very much we appreciate the
support and by the way if your ma
club is up for renewal please do
consider renewing and if you're
subscribed hit the notification bell hit
all notifications on YouTube and of
course Crowder bits is another channel
right now and the podcasts are available
on audio all this month all the good
morning mutt club as well that's uh it's
not iTunes anymore it's Apple podcasts
Android all over the place I don't know
where everywhere but after we did the
CNN stream so I went home you know
there's always a little you always a
little bit wired right you don't get
wind down this looks easy but it should
be but it's not in the news and so right
away I saw this article at CNN bring
this up this overlay given it said order
calls out dr. Burks it's a mixed message
first off I didn't have that initial
thumbnail yeah so I don't know who
Borger was I thought it was a hockey
player that was ray Borg you know the
Coyotes will be commenting on dr. Brooks
and how did he get so quickly this is I
want to be really clear about that this
is going to be a little bit long but
it's a three minute clip but I want you
to see the clip in its entirety because
this is remarkable to me when CNN when
they talk about you know these other
outlets it's important to have
legitimate news that's what right dealt
with all the small it's important that
real news Carson post information then I
see this headline
borge what does it Borg swats down
hooker border border was it saying a
given I came a Border Collie miss out
there given it's like a flail it calls
out dr. Brooks it might be a Young Turks
title right exactly I expected to see a
side by side with Mike Tyson and Ana
Kasparian I said okay well I need to
watch this they're calling her out so
it's going to be maybe like some live
fat some live fact-checking did this
morning maybe yesterday right maybe
Burke's who's very fetching by the way
yeah I missed something
yeah and I spoke this is so that's the
title and this was keep in mind too this
was the article this was the headline
that's the title it was approved by
Apple news because I saw it in my Apple
newsfeed official at first before we run
it I clicked the video and I actually
stopped it and I scrolled down because I
thought maybe this is one of those
things were it's like a video ad res
clearly not what I'm supposed to be
shamed
else misses legitimate news titled
border calls out dr. Burks right after
the press conference approved by Apple
News
this is the entirety of content from
real news are you successful safely have
hair salons and nail salons and tanto
twirlers burgers eventually poor people
how to inherently be close together I
think what I've been trying to
communicate over the last several days
is it's really important that the
governors and mayor's communicate
critical information to their
communities and show very clearly the
data we remember we wanted this data and
evidence because it was healthy on a
community water community opening
because there are different communities
in different places even in Georgia and
so I believe people in Atlanta would
understand that if their cases are not
going down that they need to continue to
do everything that we said for two full
minutes washing your hands wearing a
mess robbing copyright laws social
distance and do those things then they
can do those things I don't know how but
people are very creative so I'm not
going to prejudge but we have told
people very clearly and the president
guidelines made it very clear about the
expectations of phase one and remember
phase one also is our body this is the
original CNN any place that was
entertainments and keeping your own
individual social groups to less than
ten and we've been very clear in the
guidelines and I think it's up to the
governors and mayor's to ensure that
they're following the best they can each
of those phases to make sure that both
of the public does completion and
headline right governor's original
contrary this is it is for decision
making and make that transparent and
available to their community and again
it's this kind of a mixed message don't
worry don't pay attention to the
guidelines that we have offered you
from the administration I understand the
need to kind of be correct here and not
be you know attack people etc but I
think when people are looking for
straight answers from the medical
community
she was my interest rate order right I
think that an answer would have been
look if I were the governor of that
state I'm not so sure I would do this
look it there look at their look at
their curve
let's see where there was that rewind
three times down over two weeks the
president indicated that he's gonna talk
to the Georgia governor about the
opening of Beauty Salons etc but I think
in this circumstance and maybe I'm wrong
Sanjay maybe you know maybe there works
for nothing we spent a lot of time on
this we're trying to help you save lives
in your communities that is the entirety
of border calling out dr. Brooks which
by the way hey how is that not anti
science when people say why should I
want to defer the experts border border
suppose the expert here we had I think
two and a half minutes of just running a
clip from the press conference and then
Borger repeating herself saying nothing
well this is not this is not what I like
well yeah so the clip in the clip dr.
Burke said we want people to follow the
guidelines we've said us we've set aside
she said well you know if she's just
gonna say don't pay attention to our
guidelines she did the opposite of what
she said because talking about the face
for as well which is a new component to
the gun but I want to be clear because
on YouTube when we've done the Oscar
stream where we frankly have games we
have guests you have people in fish and
costumes and cocktail outtro fairly
transformative we get dinged and taken
down
CNN runs basically a clip from the White
House with 30 seconds of let's find
something to say
there's
no one here super intelligent to say it
I don't know let's toss let's toss on
wolf / Sanjaya doesn't even look like a
surgeon and border so guess what what
you just said is [ __ ] and right now
we just did the exact same job that you
did only a little more thorough let's
see if this gets taken down from YouTube
let's click that for crowder rights and
see cuz we're just as good as CNN it's
important that there are legitimate news
outlets out there willing to call out
non-expert Borger well and she even laid
out a case where she said look if you
can come up with a creative way to do
this and today appropriately I think you
should be able to and then burger comes
burger comes on and says oh my gosh if I
was the person doing it well you're not
and there's a reason you're not you
aren't Santa
I think masks so they're reusing the
exact mock Donald Trump mercilessly as
well as a private sector saying there's
no possible way to D to disinfect to
sanitize mass and now 800,000 a you're
not creative you're a political hack
you're somebody who's put in a quadrant
view and by the way you're in the same
room you just want to make it seem a
little more international and so you
just say well she said this but I don't
like that she said this yeah we really
need you legacy media right and that was
really the only thing that they could
pull from yesterday's conference because
when we talked about it the press
briefing was very cordial for the most
part Donald Trump answered the questions
very well he does take a lot of bites
clear anything like that there weren't
really any fireworks and we were like
what are they gonna pick for tomorrow
because they're gonna have to pick
something right to say oh I can't
believe where she said creation exactly
know exactly what they're going to do
right some people get creative that was
a nice sort of little toss and like some
people get creative I've seen people
wearing you know like masks that look
like bumblebees you know yeah well yeah
so and again people on the right I don't
know doctor birches political persuasion
but people on the right believe in
American ingenuity but they believe in
personal creativity and not that they
need to be managed from the up from the
heights of power right yeah so the right
has a an entirely different foundation
for the worldview exactly and the the
argument from Authority you know the
logical fallacies when they use at CNN a
lot and I think in this case though in
in borders defense she doesn't want to
defer to the medical expert a doctor
because she doesn't know what it is she
thinks she's talking to one
right Sanjay Blitzer right wolf lowest
score ever on celebrity jeopardy which
means one of ya
either a she's colorblind which could
view progress or CNN cannot be bothered
with the budget of making sure that
their co-host has an operating skype
right or audio because I'm sure that
they don't sound the same either ringing
has that ringing in there on their audio
that's that like like insane her Private
Ryan when when Tom Hanks is looking
around yeah it's carrying his army is
that tinnitus that's that's the best you
have to offer maybe that's what
distracted her from that's 24/7 yeah it
is easy to mix up it is Sanjay Gupta
with the widest person and a person who
is a doctor from Wolf's lowest score
ever on celebrities on J dr. Sanjay
Gupta
I mean first off the name let alone the
look right it would be like confusing
Larry Bird with Barack Obama's
half-brother yes well she got a little
like spicy too and she did it live right
Sanjay you know I started to get a
little she was expecting a shot but
instead wolfs was like what do you think
would happen in a fight between Wolf
Blitzer and Joe Biden he's going oh my
god they're telling me that Joe Biden
could actually hold it just both forget
to get off the stool yeah and they would
think that they huh
what yeah just do as much you tell them
that are going to fight but actually
just place them on a treadmill and uh
he's got great footwork of a mirror okay
you know what actually
before we move on we're going to be
talking about the death rates I need a
I'll need to actually fix some
statements that I made yesterday but
before that actually we know the lot of
you and let us know when we have some
chats they're given and let a chat with
us so of course that's a blaze TV live
let us know what you'd like to see let
us know if you want us by the way to
continue good morning mug club we can do
two shows a day every no but after
you'll be looking at what it is you guys
like we've thought about maybe doing two
late nights per week - good morning my
clubs and splitting them up said be cool
kind of like both they think that you
know you might go through withdrawals
but the point is no always more content
if you join Mudd Club but I know a lot
of you like some people here who work in
the office and so um we'd really do none
of this happens without this wonderful
team of people right and I want to say
this because I give people flack a lot I
really don't actually I'm more
apologetic than really the flack kind of
boss I'm sorry wait I was in your way
[Laughter]
walking past each other right and Wade
says don't don't ever let it happen
again
all right that's the second time this
week I'll accept it once but I will say
this I don't know we're not all in this
together we really aren't and largely
because I think people here I think we
all probably had coronavirus in January
yeah and let me explain to you why given
here we lovingly refer to as gurbles I
don't know why but how could that be
lovingly oh wait a second un warns
pandemic will cause famines of biblical
proportions
and no report on the death rates no
report on the new New England of
Medicine Journal we're going to get to
an accession with - ladies and they look
at the actual antibody right no
reporting of the 70% reduced
death rate in Florida this is and by the
way they're not citing somebody here's
understand someone important it could be
just someone in Britain you know yeah
well you know I'll think four actually
if you open up the economy yet you can
have you can have like an epic problem
what's what's the word what's better
valve there you have it rebel Wilson has
found it off Oh biblical proportion that
sounds more my gosh hair not what they
choose to cover it's what they choose
not to cover exactly but I am very so
we're not all in this together I think
we did have coronavirus um explain to
you why because Gibbon gurbles hattis we
think so did Bryce who works out there
to cute Madam's died she almost was
scared she's almost dead because she
went to Disney World
did you ever first off I advised her
against going to Disney World
be criticized little
and even if she doesn't wade into the
crocodile pit which seems very imprudent
to have a Disney World by the way
dangerous just couples like do not go to
Disney World
bad idea and she came back with I was
making jokes when she came I'm like what
you get SARS like ha ha this is before
coronavirus I was still making - no
jokes and you took it from me before the
SARS jokes from me now what am i what do
I have left
jokes about Wolf Blitzer and in the
mighty so we don't want the mighty so we
did they had it that doesn't mean
everyone else has it until you consider
that you consider that Gibbon along with
mani
brendan myself and my father do Jiu
Jitsu three times difficult to do social
distancing when someone's ghee is being
wrung out into your mouth huh like the
embalming fluid in that what was that
horror film from Sam Raimi yeah drag me
to hell damn it that would have been so
much better if I knew the film I think
so clone can do it later so uh that
beings I think we all had it but I am
incredibly grateful for of all the
things that I swear to you honestly
every morning when I pray I hit my knees
I thank thank God for my wife for the
ability to make a living the fact that
you guys give me the ability and all of
us to make a living the team of people
who surround me and quit trip I also
think wow and then I make a deal with
the devil if he'll get rid of 7-elevens
and race cross roads the problem is I
don't I don't play a mean banjo and so
to make a deal I didn't know the rules
right you got a hedge a little just felt
perturbed it was I was more of an
inconvenience I think it was a fiddle to
the Prince of Darkness really Beelzebub
is a little bit more minimal to it bill
Zebub will listen if I go down I'm like
you know what I can play the pantsuit
okay I'll see what I can do maybe
7-eleven to you know run a damp cloth
over the bathroom so they don't look
like a Turkish prison but I don't know
you know I'll have to run it up the
flagpole with Satan and I gotta tell you
Satan's a big fan of 7-eleven so we've
worked long and hard on those bathrooms
my poverty line Otis he's sick and the
CEOs chair like ya make the bathrooms
dirtier
put hookers names on the numbers one
digit short yeah Sanjay Gupta but
certainly why not walk in and say what
did I tell you
even though I never spoke with them and
is he telling me and they're very
confused so but there's a whole team of
people who make this happen here and
that's why you're joining Mudd Club
makes a big difference yes thing and I
want to kind of show you what it is that
people do show you how the sausage is
made and so we've done this before but
um it's time for people at work let's go
check it out wow did we this is that a
copyrighted song right royalty free
royalty free version yeah we got you
light there smooth mani we got ya I let
everyone know about what you said about
old people yesterday oh look I'm on a
monitor okay come on let's go here and
see the people who are here at work
- cute maddie is looking away because
she's cases right see he has a problem
Oh where's your math well let's get rid
of the old mask and put on I'm sorry
about this is embarrassing I'm sorry
about that put on the math and Brendon
Oh oh my god I mean I thought he did
that in the alley and that's a much
safer place I see him do that all I
didn't check the money back before we
went out there that's a shame really
expect to coughing the fire marshal yeah
some and the DEA know what we're not FCC
compliance so we do have a beer fridge
here oh good whatever makes people more
productive I'm fine with I don't know
it's the fire hazard
this crack make people more productive
generally Britain just wrote an entire
season of gosh the Aaron Sorkin you're
so much worse than bill and I decide
something because that was terrible she
has a romantic history before him let
him know I love how normally he just
like throws these jabs out for fun and
now that we've put him on the spot he's
like yes yes truths from Columbia and I
just assumed there's some kind of a
cultural gap right I was talking about
dr. Burks and I went home dr. Britto
murder last night she's the foxy lady
I've used the term fetching and by the
way people talk about rape culture here
including show the highlight reel from
yesterday to dr. Burke's chew be
flattered we said very fetching that
she's an attractive older lady she puts
herself together well she's articulate
the worst thing what did you say Donald
Trump oh I I just yeah like a
calculating I guarantee you dr. Burks
would not be offended she probably
because she start speaking well no but
she has to she really has to make the
310 day you know Baha so it is just
another just another thing that bothers
me this idea of rape culture
we complement women even if he can't put
compliment women overtly in a way that
borders on inappropriate funny it's okay
sometimes just compliment iams
yeah so anyway I brought it up with
smooth Manny he came by the house
because that we his he has a child and
they don't we have a super freeze or
supersized freezer and oh wow they have
a lot of a breast milk you know the
thing that woman free right you had they
say I never know how to approach it and
he's like hey can I come and get some
using you know when prep women get
pregnant they're right right I have a
pregnant wife and my wife hit me with a
trick question
Manny's wife she goes oh my gosh didn't
you notice how big valves boobs are my
wife said to this to me never marry
concern was just how much of a tell is
there on my face that I'm lying you got
to get on one of these like well I think
I went too far and I said I'm not a
thought to long yes with my
sister-in-law she was she's pregnant
things when a woman is smaller as right
Manny's wife isn't then my sister-in-law
is very tall and slim like my wife and
her testicles were very large and my
there was a first term I really
appreciated inner no where are sorry
that the bachelor night and then we also
met what was I guess they both happened
on the same night yeah we were at an
arcade that night and there was a
picture of my brother with my
sister-in-law and what happened was like
she happens to jump in the picture and
so and she was by the way she was
wearing like a long-sleeve t-shirt there
was nothing at all in her conserve but
the first thing you saw were the in my
brother my brother untagged himself in
the face really simply based on the fact
that there were large breasts in the
picture really I'm a bit surprised by
that I'm not
they were fully covered okay what is
this Detroit bus driver dies from the
Ovid 19 days after emotional released
all around great man
it's Dimond and mr. I was a black Dame
Edna
case you guys know um listen it's sad I
would see the bus trip but you know what
else to said a black man being dragged
off a bus being roughed up by police
officers because I didn't put on a mask
well but so this is this story is
obviously designed to pull at your
heartstrings of course it said of course
having an emotional plea 19 what
happened what exactly what what did this
person have pre-existing conditions were
they say before this like was there
something else going on at diabetes what
was this person have died if they had
contracted the average strain of
influenza like right all of that
information is useful for us otherwise
we think oh my gosh heartless people
yeah heartless terrible world by the way
do we have some chat to get to there uh
gurbles yeah we got a few okay let me
have a final story about the death rates
and correcting myself definitely so
first up we got Prince Spencer Steven do
you agree with the decision to shut down
the entire country do you think that a
year from now or two Trump or any other
leader is going to be like I will tell
you it's a miracle of this coming
through this is coming through blaze
chat which means it's person as a mug
club member right clearly never watch
the show say maybe he's looking for a
bit more information I don't have any
more beyond me three hours of show right
we have another chat is YouTube good you
should go you should go and live in
Schenectady with a washing machine do
you dope dummy no I'm just listen right
don't think it was good to shut down the
entire country if that's not a question
I obviously don't I mean some people
have made the argument that with the
information that they had that it was a
good idea at the time and I don't know
that that I think at the time social
distancing and Prakash it's different
washing your hands I think at the time
what would have been more prudent is
telling everyone to wear a mask at riot
point as well but they were not
concerned about people in medical fields
I think that once the media realizes
that people are a little fed up with
sitting at home for a long time I think
that they'll start saying that Trump
overreacted right
it'll be really easy to just go the
populous route and know the papers that
they're doing now I saw Huffington Post
yesterday their homepage was how Cove it
affects the body long term and kovat is
just a warm-up for what's coming next
right so they're giving from this is the
worst to you ain't love or see yeah I'm
getting too old for this [ __ ]
still I mean now they're using every
case or some sad case of somebody dying
to illustrate this sort of flurry of
fear rather than data-driven rather than
objective its look at this story and yes
listen course there's a sad story you
can also find sad stories of people who
die from the flu every year you can find
stories of people who die from their
area those sad stories exist all over
the place in car accidents because
they're going to work every absolutely
we're not minimizing any of that but
then this is not a sustainable response
this cannot be how we respond even if
there is a 2% death rate which there's
absolutely no we're gonna we'll get into
that well gay but even if their work
that's not how we can respond and have a
functioning society long term to
situations like this is just a bad I
didn't keep in mind they did say that
they hoped we had a recession so that
they could lay it at Donald Trump's feet
Oh words and basically highs like it's
worth it I take them videos on give me
another chat they're given and then
we'll close this thing out yes Dylan is
wondering why is the mainstream media so
adamant about keeping the American
people locked up in their homes for as
long as possible because Donald Trump
created the best economy that we've seen
in the modern American era they had a
vested interest in it being crippled
they said as much and they want to keep
it that way going into election what
right and then yeah it's the opposite
position of Donald Trump right whatever
that position Donnell they tend to take
they knew Donald Trump I really think
you should continue with that term
yesterday the full employment
yeah that's not just a low unemployment
it's a high labor force participation
rate it's a job surplus it's more people
in the workforce we were at full
employment with more raises to the
annual salary and we've talked about
this before to some Cup tennis people
just be you they talk about income and
they say well it's not even outpacing
inflation and what they're referring to
is average hourly earnings as opposed to
average individual income reg is more
appropriate and that's always actually
even under Barack Obama even under
Clinton that's always outpaced inflation
by a significant margin down but for the
first time now you have average hourly
well you did average hourly earnings
pacing inflation I think average hourly
earnings were 5% which I don't even know
how you do that because as far as I'm
concerned slapping together a
filet-o-fish today is worth just as much
as it was 10 years ago is it just as
much as it wasn't 72 the [ __ ] but yeah
that has gone up even in the age of
automation so he had an economy that
wasn't just the stock market by the way
it wasn't just the Dow Jones as people
wanted to say but we had an economy that
undeniably was helping everybody in Main
Street America and at this point they if
it's the economy stupid they want it to
be the coronavirus stupid and the
response yes and they want you to
remember it and here's the thing so do i
I want you to remember this I don't only
want you remember this is November I
want you to remember this at the 4th of
July I want you to look back and say
gosh remember when Sanjay Gupta / Wolf
Blitzer I can't tell them apart said
that we're not going to be able to have
the force of July yeah I want you to
remember this this was the play and I we
weren't Donald Trump guys in the primary
no I don't think he's he's been a
perfect president but in areas like this
he has handled it superbly and certainly
before this he did more for the economy
than any modern president I think
definitely I see moderate present I
would say more than Ronald Reagan I
think they thought that Trump this was
gonna destroy Trump oh he's not gonna be
able to handle it right it's done it's
brought the presidential like out of him
it's made him look better yeah I made
him yeah mate it makes the American
people go oh he can handle crisis and
the evening briefings very very clever
on his part because it was basically a
dare and they decided to not run it and
people now like you said people are
stuck at home guess what people are
stuck at home and they'll watch anything
but CNN it's kind of like we have a map
yeah
two of the same was it two two
positively charged yeah you can't get it
that's what people do at home if it's
seen and they'll find anything else Dog
Whisperer Westminster cat show animals
honors for some time stuck in my head
anything but CNN and so they stumble
across the press briefing and go oh yeah
what and I think to what we're gonna see
is that and waiting you and I were
talking about this before the show I
think we we danced a lot closer to
potentially losing democracy and losing
freedom and liberty than we think we did
in many ways we have yeah well and it's
not and what we're saying it's not the
guy in power at the time typically
that's the problem right when you do
when you make you know like all these
concessions with liberties like oh well
know this person
won't take advantage of it it's the next
guy or the guy after that I will say it
yeah I was just gonna say anybody who is
saying July you have to celebrate for
the Independence Day from your home
sitting around not talking anybody mark
them right these are people yeah poppy
Harlow and Jim fourth of July but yeah
again if you're not if yes I really hope
that they let us leave our homes for
Independence Day right yeah it's scary
and these are people by the way and keep
in mind as well they want you to stay
home and they want you to be dependent
on the government
yeah they want you to see they'll not be
able to work so that they can implement
permanent income permanent and what's
the term again for the universal income
a universal synonym they want that to be
permanent so Independence Day they want
you to stay home and be entirely
dependent on daddy be entirely dependent
on Big Brother which you know is
remarkable because you would think they
wouldn't want people dependent on the
federal rock with a president Donald
Trump right right but the process which
is named on the text overall they're
thinking this is going to be short-lived
which I think you might be surprised and
they want ultimately the American people
to be dependent on the government they
want to be able to control the American
people ultimately and I will say this
this has made me leery of my neighbor in
a lot of ways when I have an it and I
don't mean an actual neighborhood right
my neighbors a really nice guy well stop
going through my mail I get it that
you're 85 but it's a federal offense it
really is
sir so I come home from I took your
mailing took the liberty to that I need
that Frederick's of Hollywood catalog ah
so I'm down this year so wish list I
hope to see dr. Burks
what was I saying before this my name is
Natalie Shore saying hey I want to
report this guy for not social
distancing yeah kissing his wife or hey
these people are putting my life at Dane
first first off if someone goes out to a
park they're not putting your life and
down what are the masks and wash your
hand and shut up
I'm sorry or you can stay home but you
shouldn't require that everybody else
stay home especially when we get to
these numbers here regarding the death
rates that have nobody this is amazing
to me because this should be the story
today because we a now have three
different studies looking at antibodies
and all of them by
'we are pretty congruent in what they
tell us about the infection rate that's
what's remarkable multiple real studies
that tell us the infection rate at the
lowest is 25 times higher than we
thought to 60 the average is about 48 so
I do actually need to make sure that
right now III I fix something that it
yesterday about the death rates I did
speak too soon and I do need to issue a
correction
[Music]
then I stoped myself thanks for you
thanks if you're looking for me to
recant my World Health Organization
commentary you'll be sorely disappointed
well it's cuz true unless quick trip
wants me to in which I never even heard
it's a big quick trip huh they got their
hooks in you
Taiwan II got so I talked about this the
day where I said you know the death rate
was between 0.5 ret and point 0 2
percent I was specifically referring to
the USC Los Angeles County study and how
that actually sort of correlated with
the Santa Clara County study well
there's a new one that just came out
this is they tested pregnant women right
yeah co-ed in New York New York City
yeah a whopping 15 percent tested
positive yeah 15 percent of pregnant
women tested positive so according to
this article that means that the
infection rate of the population I think
it's the pregnant population but overall
the population is that minimum 11 to 14
times higher than they previously
thought then the two hundred and
something thousand cases they have right
now right so when you take that and you
take the the the USC study by the way
where the I think it was yeah that's
right the USC studies showed that it was
twenty five to fifty eight times more
likely the infection read antibody study
not a bastion of republicanism USC then
they said it was likely fifty to eighty
times more likely and so you add it all
up I said the death rate would be
between zero I think zero point to what
I said zero point in point zero two five
five sorry no in New York were said it's
worse this means that right now it's
between zero point seven and that's
including all deaths by the way all
deaths all deaths including old people
diabetics people with hypertension and
then if you actually eliminate according
to the New York statistics because we're
data-driven not talking about granted a
tragic sob story on CNN data does matter
according to New York they said
ninety-five percent of cases are either
old people or people with comorbidities
yeah let's scale that back let's just
say nineteen Italy it was 98 in New York
it was ninety five percent but let's say
that ninety percent of these deaths in
New York somewhere between nineteen
thousand and twenty thousand right are
old people so you take that number and
you times it by 0.1 that gives you the
total number right okay that means that
in New York the death rate is zero point
seven percent tops
tops and on the low end for healthy
adults meaning of average age you could
be 40 you could be 50 point zero five
percent Wow yeah that's that's a very
low number point zero percent you can
see low by the way as low as point zero
percent clears yesterday when we were
using the number I was using 80% of
cases only the other people so if using
its override there didn't get it every
time Thank You GU overlords just keep
pushing we should have listened taiwan
going to bed first or a quick trip
either one either one either pig well
it's even one of the things I swore to
you when you asked me yesterday what do
you think they're gonna talk about I was
sure that they were gonna bring up these
studies and say hey we probably have a
higher infection rate I've done some
more research since then and some people
have said it but they've said it in a
negative way every single time they talk
about these infection rates being higher
they're not using what they're not using
that right now on CNN they're saying
this many people have been infected this
many people have died they're not using
that they're saying well this is worse
but they're saying far more widespread
than we thought well that means it's
actually right there's a lower mortality
rate less deadly that's a good thing yes
so that that number going up is the
bottom number of the fractions right as
that number goes up that means a smaller
death rate mathematics and so you're not
a math Asian something else it's pretty
important to notice they keep saying and
by the way deaths that have happened at
home so undoubtedly the overall death
rate will go higher no no no won't know
because most people aren't dying at home
by the way most people are actually
dying in rifles and then you're adding
several thousand more to the total death
rate as we saw in New York City and only
3,000 people say we're pretty sure they
had coca so the death rate honestly is
probably higher it's inflated certainly
we're and it's obviously certainly
higher if you're just talking about the
average healthy American because you're
including people I guess study with the
chloroquine they haven't had an average
of three pre-existing conditions and
they were all over 65 years old no the
death rate really should go down when
you eliminate if you just right now
eliminate all the deaths registered that
were never tested for kovat boom you cut
that down by I don't know how many
thousands there was a limit imagine in
one day and then you multiply the
infection rate by at minimum 20 times
potentially 60 or 80 times according to
Santa Clara let's split it down the
middle and say forty times you're
looking at a death rate there
comparable to the flute not saying you
shouldn't it precautions
it's a communicable disease in the flu
but not nearly as deadly as we were led
to believe and I don't believe I make no
apologies certainly not a reason to shut
down the economy take away everyone's
laughing yeah well if it's a fraction
again the top numbers going down the
bottom numbers going up that means
smaller yeah yeah there's there's good
news but instead we have to play a story
about a bus driver who died which is sad
I get it but there's great news out
there guys hey this probably isn't
killing nearly as many people who get
this virus as we thought that should be
banner headline news front page of every
newspaper in the country and it's not
being covered at all and by the way see
this right now they say Georgia
coronavirus hospitalizations if we can
bring this up actually given as an
overlay we had this yesterday where they
were saying remember when this initially
started you don't need to bring up stars
at CNN but you can just show up we don't
need to listen to it they're talking
about more hospitalizations in Georgia
okay the the number that matters is the
deaths per capita that's the number that
matters that's the only one that you can
accurately gauge at this point
hospitalizations are very subjective
because some people go to the hospital
early some people go to the hospital
late now yeah early on and we ran this I
think as a meme with the then and now
they told what did they tell you if you
were young you didn't have pre-existing
studies and you saw symptoms they said
stay away from the hospital don't go and
don't infect anybody else and then now
because they have empty hospitals
they've built new hospitals no one's
over filling them and that they're
panicking and they have to furlough
workers have to lay them off now they
are saying and this was on CNN I believe
yesterday they're saying people are
waiting too long to go to the hospital I
need to go to the hospitals right away
well there you go that right there can
affect if you have that on the media a
broadcast like a morphine drip I go to
the hospital go to the hospital go to
hospital have a cough
go to the hospital runny nose go to
hospital right away take no chances that
will increase hospitalizations have the
deaths correlated directly with
increased hospitalizations no no they
haven't
right that's what matters so when they
say look at this hospitalizations are
going up people are resisting opening
and opening up in Jordan no more people
are go to the hospital because you've
told them now that they should go to the
hospital when you told them that they
shouldn't just like people are wearing
masks now because you're telling them
that I should wear masks when before you
told them that they shouldn't but that
doesn't mean that the death rate per
capita is going up in Georgia it doesn't
mean that is becoming more deadly it
that more people are making the decision
to go to the hospital likely because
they're driving by going it looks pretty
empty I'll take a shot at a test right
exactly
well let's remember we shut down the
economy for one reason only right it was
to make sure that we did not overwhelm
the hospital system in the United States
that was it
we had to flatten the glass in the car
that's what I got a crazy light yeah
guess what we didn't even come close
bring this back up scene and look
hospitalization they're going up someone
bring up the deaths in Georgia for me
can we do that bring up the deaths in
Georgia yeah then I want to save them
directly correlates to the
hospitalizations
not if deaths have gone up they can go
up but do they correlate directly with
the hospitalizations because that is the
number that matters and the governor is
saying we are past the peak well if yeah
it just goes to show that no matter what
numbers you throw at CNN or CNN puts on
it will always be spun into fear right
there's no way of interpreting it in any
kind of positive way you're not allowed
to be happy right right in context
matters for this like a service to the
American public would be to say here the
numbers that the CDC is putting out
which is that right so right CDC's not
doing anything wrong by saying here are
the numbers CNN is doing something wrong
saying not doing this next part saying
here are the numbers and here's what
they mean right right that's what should
be being said to the American people to
give you an accurate picture because
guess what the next time if something
like this happens and it has a 6 7 8
percent mortality rate right and they
people aren't going to believe that they
cried wolf this time and they had their
one shot to be honest we are the little
boy who cried pandemic they are point
about them spinning fear yeah remember
they did this with like Halloween razors
in the end yes every every few years
that comes out right which think about
it if you're crazy enough to put a razor
blade in someone's Apple the kind of
crazy who wants to see the smile on
their face so why would you do it and
you don't even get to see the meat the
Apple it doesn't make sense they'd
likely never happened they said it
certainly it wasn't the epidemic I
assumed it was actually true no that's
interests now it's like they wanted us
to think that every single person giving
you money for your UNICEF bonds Michael
Keaton in Pacific Heights
there was any one guy candy right do we
have those numbers they're given just
give me a nod or no I can't hear you so
I can't see you in Georgia yeah we got
one 1,300 Georgians were hospitalized no
no I mean the death rates if we have
those we can get those so see if reg can
get the death yeah I want to see how
many people of Georgia and if it
directly correlates and we can bring
that up by going a world a meter and hit
in USA and Georgia I already know the
answer I just want to make sure that you
don't think I'm lying okay right you
have to smoked again please do consider
obviously joining up at mug Club we will
be tonight doing an ash wednesday and
then tomorrow we have Ted Cruz I'm Joe
Friday and Crenshaw and of course thank
you to our wonderful sponsors Walter if
you need a firearm this is basically
their cool deadly they sell themselves
yeah try the Walker you purchase a
firearm they have the balls to sponsor
the shore and black rifle sure they have
a common lash crowd enter the promo code
Crowder and you get 20% off if you drink
coffee and you like good coffee toss an
actual house and drink a veteran owned
company and drink the product from the
veteran owned company don't drink a gun
and accompany that Daniel need some
pepcid ac we in have them as a sponsor
yet or hydrochloric when one of the two
yeah alka-seltzer it's all the same
thing
and but they're also they are quick trip
they sell guns they have a lot of
chlorine turn that promo code okay time
for a little what is this what's going
on at carnivores killed Americans weeks
earlier than thought oh you mean there's
more information that you guys were
wrong
standing that this is these these papers
are not the same as a paper that is
already told the story and Santa Claus
is coming to town by the way can I can I
make one point and she looks like if you
took Helen punch the fan you shrunk it
in Photoshop without hanging shift so no
just give every single story that I've
seen them kind of pivot back to is about
how hydrochloric Queen and the president
was wrong
yeah none of this works and it's like
okay guys that was one study right
there's a lot of context that you need
for that the president wasn't wrong when
he said I don't know maybe I hope it
could be a game-changer for us that's
not wrong to say oh sorry I'm just no
I'm smell it no I'm listening I'm
smelling is that coffee there was it was
because you know what happens the bag
gets puffy that's how you know it's
fresh roasted has in the carpet is the
off gas so that's not so remember the
other day I squeezed it all I got all
the sniffs I was very selfish my
business yeah very inconsiderate but I
didn't I love this sniffs cuz it comes
out of the little valve and just now I
realize that I've gotten puffy again
because of the off gassing I just got
some more some more coffee sniffs well
so this do you should do something for
Joe Biden you should put like little
girls smell in a bag for Joe to just
cheese who needs the bag Oh God he needs
a bag it would be helpful if your wife
if you're watching don't say that just
to know that [ __ ] okay oh hey we've got
the the numbers okay reg yeah what do we
have on the reg 49 million sorry
seventy-nine that's per million
seventy-nine deaths per million and what
I would be interesting to see is we
can't bring it up right now but to see
where they're showing look more
hospitalizations that is happening
across the board I can say across the
country you'll but there are more
hospitalizations and in many cases fewer
deaths you're talking about a graph yeah
and if you take away obviously if you
take away the 3,000 and your guess is as
good as mine being tossed up there that
red never tested positive for kovat you
can't just talk about hospitalizations
just like you can't just talk about
infection rates you have to talk about
deaths specifically deaths per capita
that is the number that matters I
disagree with ben shapiro because he was
talking about the mortality rate well
guess what that just changed like Edie
Rooney's computer with Ferris Bueller's
absent the only number that you can rely
upon without human intervention human
error are the deaths per million at this
and even then there's still not that
reliable because they are skewed by them
adding to the total deaths and at least
it puts it somewhat in context whereas
the hospitalizations that can be
directly affected right this is the same
reason you have insider trading loss it
can be directly affected by someone
going up going up going wherever they go
they're not going up any more there's no
state they're gone going on over to
their laptop right without a microphone
and talking about hospitalizations and
telling people you need to go to the
hospital you need to go to the hospital
you need to go to the hospital yeah we
said you shouldn't go to the hospital
but now we're saying you need to go to
the hospital you need to go as soon as
possible what do you think's going to
happen you have the you have the ability
to directly influence the market and
force more people into the hospital and
so you say hospitalizations are up but
guess what more people going to the
hospital has led us to be able to
conduct more antibody tests right we've
referred to and that has let us know
uh-oh CNN that it's 20 to 60 times more
prevalent than we thought and that
brings the death rate down to 0.5 tops
potentially point 0 2 percent right but
you only cover the hospitalizations
because you told people to do it well
all right two points one those things
lag sometimes those numbers do and two
well how many people were in the ICU
that went to the hospital how many
people just came in and we're feeling
bad but we're being able to be treated
normally how many people needed a
ventilator like all of those things
would matter for that number to make any
any sense for us at all otherwise it's
just a random number not gonna lie to
you you I didn't listen to you at all
because four people don't know the
monitor is hereness the Sarah McLachlan
animal what I'm trying about blinders on
it's like I listen I've rescued dogs
okay I'm doing my part stop bombarding
me how many times can you blame that
commercial I just want to laugh at Wolf
Blitzer and Sanjay which i think is
wrong I don't think I'm supposed to
you're not supposed to lie supposed to
tune in to laugh at a very white
[ __ ] you're not allowed I want to
see a Sarah McLaughlin clip with all of
Wolf Blitzer looking sad rescuing Wolf
Blitzer Oh
Suman on a nostril flare I want to see
the commercial of like a bra for the
price of a cup of coffee a day you can
put Wolf Blitzer on a ventilator and
even though there's no one just because
he wants one Oh
my window no a very bizarre commercial
and then I would say what did I tell you
about this commercial even I never
really told you anything and I like go
to the 7-eleven stall whoa Fletcher was
here like the daughter picture of Sanjay
Gupta okay so some people is saying they
like kind of when I tell some
behind-the-scenes stories a boxer's
people were not happy about it at MSNBC
I'll tell you that oh but I think I've
told this story before do you guys know
this story then we have to go and we
will see you tonight with Ash Wednesday
about when I met Clint Eastwood no okay
Clint Eastwood so I met him a couple of
times and this is just sort of an amount
of the two different times but both
interactions are technically three
interactions
we're very Clint Eastwood II so let me
preface this by saying I think you guys
know we've had some celebrities in
studio obviously have celebrities on
skype it's it's sort of in an eight
quality I haven't that I don't tend to
get intimidated by celebrity you can
call that being on the spectrum because
I pretty much just treat them as I treat
most people in this room that being said
there is a certain level of celebrity
and fame with which I'm no longer
comfortable and that basically is like
Clint Eastwood Spielberg and Tom Hanks
like that pretty much and the way you
treat people in this room is with total
disdain which was my instinct with Clint
Eastwood like hey I loved you in any
whatever but loose weight finally
warming up here and starting to throw
some jabs a little late Wade pan because
I believe that the orangutangs
performance was more impressive for
anyone hasn't seen that film and it's
Clint Eastwood street fighting as
clinics where's the Street Fighter and
there's a motorcycle gang called the
black widows and they're the most inept
post of five get the bikes like some guy
pokes them over with a pool cue know
like the wild this is like a PG comedy
isn't this is and there's an orangutan
named Clyde oh but he's like a Kato
where he goes to the barn and the
orangutan that comes in he's like Oh
Clyde the wrestling I'm like that's not
how this is how an orangutan surprise he
rips off your face
with a bottle of xanax red wine and the
clicker okay what's 90's in like monkey
buddy cop movies Joe do something
criticize it because I want to see them
making a comeback orangutangs back
canine with what with Jim Belushi as I
like to call him the better Belushi oh
that's a take when it comes to Belushi's
they can't all be gems yes thank you I
hate all that you are I will say this of
conservatives in Hollywood sort of see
it's not really secret anymore but it
was a secret organization at the time
concerns for conservatives in Hollywood
and I'm looking at a table and I and at
this table is Clint Eastwood Gary Sinise
Jon Voight David Mamet and there were a
few other people those were one that
really stuck out obvious like manage
yeah yeah and I okay I'm gonna go sit
you know I'm like a table 64 but Andrew
Breitbart was one who brought me in it
wasn't 2009 when I was at PJTV and
Andrew says no not Steven come come over
you're gonna sit with me have you met
Gary so I go there so I'm sitting at a
round table keep in mind with Gary
Sinise John's what Clint Eastwood and
Gary turned out he's been on the show
very very nice like he does yeah this
man alive Jason yeah I don't think I've
ever met a nicer person the kind of
person Kelsey Grammer was at the table
to I should say he's also very nice yeah
but I knew that because my mother would
work with him a long time ago at the
Just for Laughs he was nice Brett Butler
was Satan Beelzebub at least I don't
have to buy it next to so I'm sitting in
a chair god I hate you Breitbart guys
nice and we're talking so gay Sinise's
crosstalking Ross Andru with me like
pretty loud but Clint is there and he
clearly has no idea because he didn't
even know that I'm alive and I'm kind of
looking for my spot and I don't find it
to them
later he kind of walks on over to the
bar and like okay oh go go and he's
talking with someone I never want to be
that guy takes up too much time so he's
at the bar he gives the guy some cash
which I can only assume was like a
hundred
wound up and he turns around and I just
said uh he turned around into me
yeah ah and then he just looked me said
[Laughter]
later that night later there actually
would be all stand up like hi I'm
so-and-so I'm a producer hi I'm Gary
Sinise right you know man writers
writers producers you know part-time
actors comedians and then Clint Eastwood
stands up and have to introduce yourself
you know because everyone it's like
alcohol is not everyone on the same
footing Clint Eastwood stands up he goes
hi I'm Clint Eastwood former mayor of
Carmel and I'm sure everybody but it's
not a joke he went over to my I believe
my friend Alex later and I was telling
me about this but I wasn't there but he
was playing on his iPhone he's like
playing you at this point I don't know
what it might have been like flappy bird
or whatever yeah and clay so just use
walking right so picture claims but I'll
just do it rolling here he's walking and
he sees Alex over here so he's walking
and he stops and he looked down but he
looks at us he goes like like he's
disgusted facing like these nobody yeah
hey did you rescue the princess yeah
shaking up my soul former mayor of
Carmel anything bad he's a little
standoffish but he wasn't it's great the
guy had a great sense of humor he seems
pretty sharp and I'm pretty grateful
that I got to meet him okay listen
everybody we really appreciate you
tuning in again as the promo code is
quarantine you get $30 off if you join
throughout this entire months of April
we've doubled content to try and serve
you we're not first responders we're not
heroes we can just tell some jokes and
cover the news so we hope that it's been
valuable to you and that we will be here
tonight with Ash Wednesday and then
tomorrow we will be here with Ted Cruz
dancringe on Friday and next week I
should tell you next week will
a live broadcast of CNN four hours of a
fact-checking CNN live that'll be the
grand finale on Thursday I'm not looking
forward to it but I do this for you
good morning enjoy your day
[Music]